alors justement tient question avant que
charlize arrive franchement valérie
bénaïm oui c'est qu'est-ce que vous
connaissez ce film proposition industrie
où la mer m s'est tous posé la question
avec robert redford 120 millions de
dollars pour passer une nuit avec des
mii moore vous est ce que si quelqu'un
vous propose un million de dollars pour
passer mieux avec vous vous dites oui
dix balles c'est la moins chère quoi
watchers vous a déjà proposé vous oui
non et déjà quelqu'un que vous avez
besoin d'argent position indécente 7
euros c'est pourquoi soir et a déjà
proposé d'art sérieusement oui oui ça
aubin parfois quand on rencontre des
gens votent à gauche si vous proposent
parfois des choses bizarres mais ça m'a
amusé ça va cela était franchement quoi
mais vous l'avez fait non mais j'ai
pensé
ah oui ça aurait été sympa dans vidéo
gag non mais vraiment j'ai pensé parce
que c'était c'était quand même c'est
flatteur au fond et ça vous prend aussi
pour les a proposé que moi mais je suis
pas allé jusqu'à la somme finale j'ai
pas voulu demander mais on me dit
combien vous voulez ça m'a plu ça m'a
pas le sang plasma m'excite je veux dire
oui c'est vrai que c'est sur que c'est
pas tf1 puisque vous vous mariez vous
bennama non non non mais là mais la
domination le dur composé un tajine sait
qu est ce que vous voulez quoi non mais
là par exemple robert redford tient pas
la route cette boîte c'est vrai cette
histoire ça tient pas la route
un million de dollars ils sont beaux
tous les deux et c'est à elle elle va
pour doucher avec robert redford est
gratuit c'est palace et voilà je te
grattes au sahel avec robert alors et
fait même pas être est ce en quoi ça
vous fera perdre et à certains moments
je normal non plus là bas vous bon on
m'a déjà proposé sept cent mille euros
couasnon euros pour un week end entier
sur la côte d'azur avec un couple et
vous allez avec qui c'est qui c'est les
jouets on m'avait envoyé la photo de la
femme qui était très jolie
ouais antenne blonde très joli j'ai pas
vu la photo de l'homme ce qu'il fait ce
qu'il fallait faire un truc à trois noms
quelle sélection je fasse un truc avec
le mari avait après deux semaines à
l'action
j'ai dit non ils sont venus un an plus
tard proposons un million
gillet cette histoire est fausse dans
des échanges encore les échanges radio
libre aux yeux c'était un peu radin ça
va réunir cette somme ayant proposé à
mme bideau est ce que vous avez est ce
que vous avez hésité j'ai hésité à un
million d'euros c'est qu'hier j'ai
vraiment hésité et après je me suis dit
qu'est ce qu'un million après faut les
faire un truc j'ai pas envie de faire et
waco n'étaient pas amis à l'époque un
vrai conseil et frère aîné alors des
fois on fait des trucs qu'on n'a pas
envie de faire sans être payé tes babet
merci merci c'est la panne ou soirée et
vous moi c'est récent et ayant un nom
sur la côte d'azur
j'étais chez des amis et le téléphone
sonne et en fait c'était un russe je
dépanne ou un russe qui avait vu que
j'étais sur la côte d'azur parce que
j'avais mon instagram et je me passe le
téléphone et me dit ma fille c'est son
anniversaire elle vous aime beaucoup je
précise qu'elle était majeure elle avait
22 ans et il m'a dit elle vous aime
beaucoup et il m'a proposé 25000 euros
pour venir le samedi soir chez lui et il
m'a dit peut-être un peu plus si vous
êtes très gentil et que ma fille non non
entendu si j'y vois là mais il fréquente
des champions alors moi je vous dis on
va jamais rien proposé mon papa moi
jamais jamais moi y'a un truc qui se
passe on vous a proposé dix balles pour
aller vivre sans dire mais non moi y'a
un truc qui se passait depuis je suis
tout jeune c'est toujours dit combien on
proposerait pour faire avec un homme
coach hétéro je me disais qu'à un
million je le fais non un million je le
fais pas mal
il ya un truc qui use plus je vieillis
plus la somme à des sens
[Rires]